dès le départ de la petite lili cros la
martinique avec son père dans le cadre
d'un simple droit de visite
conformément à une ordonnance du 17
juillet 2015
la mère appréhendait un tel scénario je
sais qu'elle va pas revenir parce que ce
monsieur après oublier son bagage pour
l'enfant et il attend que la justice me
donne les neuf ans de prison ferme que
la substitut du procureur a décidé tout
ça parce que j'ai protégé ma fille
l'initiative de garder l'enfant est
venue du peu
malgré la décision et pendant le temps
où l'enfant était gardée des mesures ont
été prises et même accompagné par le
banquet je ne travaillerais ni je ne
mens pas et même accompagné dans le parc
est aujourd'hui stelly mère de famille
est assigné en référé devant le juge aux
affaires familiales du tribunal de
grande instance de fort-de-france par
maître guy à
avocat au barreau de la rochelle un
avocat et le père qui demande surtout
aux juges le transfert de la résidence
de la fillette de 9 ans à son domicile
il demande aussi de lui confier la garde
de cette dernière est de fixer un droit
de visite à la mère en france
après quelques minutes de débats le juge
aux affaires familiales renvoie ce
dossier à une date ultérieure et tous
nos souhaits ou et éthique 7 affirme
puisse être prise aujourd'hui
mais les conditions ne permet tait parce
que j'ai reçue non seulement
l'assignation mais également chuté dans
la foulée des conclusions complémentaire
de vous offrir ce dossier très sensible
a été renvoyé au 8 n la garde de
l'enfant est pour le moment confié au
père à la rochelle l'info a été confiée
provisoirement paix dans le parquet dans
le cadre de ses attributions
j'ai pas d'idée un dossier comme celui
là immédiatement à l'une des parties
adverses
bon ça c'est un autre débat mais c'est
pas tout de suite lider mais pourquoi
pas immédiatement ses provisions non il
des animaux
neuf donc par conséquent bon c'est
encore plus dans lequel nous sommes
obligés de nous plier m julien guillard
avance que pour des raisons techniques
la visio conférence prévue ce matin
entre la rochelle à martinique n'a pu
avoir lieu
d'autre part il précise que durant son
séjour au domicile de son père que les
lire aux eaux est fait de nouvelles
déclarations
l'enfant a fait des révélations en tout
quatre familles de galles est
parfaitement heureuse et parfaitement
bien et c'est suite à ces révélations
que le procureur de la république de
fort de france a souhaité faire entendre
cet enfant dans un cadre protégé par la
brigade des mineurs qui sont spécialisés
dans ce cadre-là ce qu'elle a dit
réserver la justice bien évidemment mais
suite à suite à cette audition
le procureur a souhaité creuser un
psychologue a été mandatée psychologue
qui a parlé avec l'enfant
d'autres les révélations ont été
confirmés et ça a fait dire au procureur
de la rochelle que l'enfant ne
repartirait pas en martinique
prochainement cette fille est au centre
des débats sera à nouveau auditionné en
présence de son avocat maître chantal
hocdé mandaté par le bâtonnier de
l'ordre des avocats de martinique
couleurs selon m guillard mais les roses
sera scolarisé provisoirement à la
rochelle